the moment of truth for boris johnson
the vote in favour
uh of having confidence in boris
johnson's leader was 211 votes and the
vote against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
148 mps voting against their pm he wins
but this is hardly a victory the cheers
and banging of desks couldn't drown out
the reality over 40 percent of the party
just voted against its leader
the pm desperate to turn the page this
is a
a very good result
for politics and for
for the country justin it's just i i do
just in in this sense i think it's a
convincing result a decisive result on
what it what it means
is that as
as a government we can move on and focus
on the stuff that i think really matters
to people but his detractors think the
damage is done
unfortunately the issue can't be settled
like that
um a third over a third
of the parliamentary party has expressed
no confidence in the prime minister
a prime minister
of honour would look at the figures
accept the fact
that
he has lost the
support of a significant proportion of
his party and consider his position the
labour leader happy to exploit divisions
in the ruling party
conservative mps
made their choice tonight
they have ignored the british public
and hitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
there had been an uneasy jubilee truce
between the pm and his party it was over
shortly after dawn as long-term johnson
ally jesse norman reignited the simran
rebellion with this letter calling the
pm's response to partygate grotesque and
calling on him to resign
confirmation quickly followed that
dozens of his colleagues agreed the
threshold of 15 to the parliamentary
party seeking a vote of confidence in
the prime minister has been passed
therefore a vote of confidence will take
place
the pm told on sunday the rebellion had
cleared its first hurdle with at least
54 of his own mps saying it was time for
him to go the cabinet dispatched to
insist he must stay i'm hoping we get
through this boat tonight and we can get
on and he's uh
he's a dead man walking thank you very
much
dead man he's a strong leader he will
get the get the big calls right and
thank you very much for all your time
but this rebellion had been building for
months bringing in all factions of the
tory party from all intakes please of
loyalists doing little to change the
minds of those out of patience like this
mp boris johnson's anti-corruption czar
resigning after concluding his boss
broke the ministerial code is he done
whichever way now
i i fear that that is probably the case
i think it's over
it feels now like a question of when not
if
at the moment in so far as anyone can
tell
it feels like the beginning of the end
and facing such an acute leadership
crisis boris johnson nowhere to be seen
in public leaving the estonian pm alone
on the doorstep of number 10 as the
british pm hid inside his political woes
disrupting the duties of leadership
and then later behind these windows he
made one last plea to his party before
the voting began stick with me he said
the best is yet to come
many of his mps now openly disagree two
and a half years ago they were cheering
boris johnson on as he won that 80-seat
majority but tonight 148
of them have said it's time for him to
go from all powerful to deeply damaged
from untouchable to deeply tarnished
once adored now held in disdain yes
boris johnson has survived the vote of
confidence but this is undoubtedly a
mortal blow to his authority and the big
question is can he ever really now
recover
the pm's allies like to say never write
off boris johnson but history says tory
leaders never shake off the damage of a
confidence vote whatever the outcome for
now he stays in office but is he really
now in power beth rigby's sky news
westminster